I now proclaim Cersei of the House
Lannister first of her name, a queen of the andals
of the first men
protector of the Seven Kingdoms
long may she reign
shame
your house disappear all memory of you
disappear you can't kill me
welcome home my queen
happy comic-con day - they actually
dropped a season seven teaser so let's
break it down I'm also going to do a
breakdown of the really important stuff
they said about season seven during the
panel there was actually a lot of season
seven news in between all the jokes that
they were telling there was a lot of
tongue-in-cheek stuff like sophie turner
was baiting the crowd a little bit
saying i totally would love to see
Littlefinger on the iron throat she got
like the shame none treatment after that
like the whole crowd was just like shame
shame how dare you suggest Littlefinger
take the Iron Throne but let's start
with the footage first so mostly what
you're seeing here is them setting up
their King's Landing set like the iron
throne room Circe's throne room her
costume you see the mountains Kingsguard armor then you see like all these
shields you see like all the stuff
that's happening at Winterfell this is
mostly hyping King's Landing Winterfell
stuff like you see Santa's chair here so
sophie turner actually said that she
believes that jon is unfit to rule
Winterfell to run it just like the way
Robert Baratheon was a terrible King an
amazing warrior but someone who has no
business running a kingdom so in her
opinion this is Sophie Turner speaking
she believes that Jon and Sansa should
rule the north as king and queen
together but not as a couple not as a
romantic couple it was actually a fan
that asked her I was kind of blown away
by this but I guess you shouldn't be
surprised but she confirmed that Jon and
Sansa will not be getting down twincest
Lannister style she's like they grew up
together they're brother and sister
no that is never going to happen so it's
not something that I ever believed was
going to happen but she did confirm like
Sansa is a little upset at the situation
the way things are going right now
it does make her sound like she's going
to be something of a bad girl in season
7 like season 7 thematically you'll see
a lot of bad girls loving to misbehave I
think about the way Cersei is the
ultimate bad girl right now Daenerys
even has a little bit of a mean streak
in her then think about Sansa what's
going on with her right now she did say
that Sansa really did enjoy getting rid of
Ramsay and that maybe now she would enjoy doing it more so it all just feels like
it's feeding into a full season of bad
girls misbehaving like if you know like
Mad Men is a show all about bad men
think about that same idea with the main
female characters for Game of Thrones
just a season of women
Behaving Badly you know you like you can
see the little bear off screen just
scowling at everyone this map here
actually offers some clarification you
see like the little dragon ships you see
the other ship markers here near the sea
of Dorne so that's where Daenerys is
sailing so we know Daenerys is going to
at least start the season down in door
like in this final shot here it was
there's some question as to like where
she was going exactly because there were
some Dornish ships in the fleet so just
a little bit of a teaser but but
obviously she's not going to spend a
whole lot of time just sitting around so
even though they might start there
they'll be sailing up to King's Landing
relatively quickly but season 7 script
hype 701 just give us a little peek
inside there I know this looks like a
real script but usually they print them
on red pages so they can't be
photocopied and they'll number the pages
there's all kinds of crazy security now
but if you ever wondered they actually
finish the story itself like the scripts
I mean even though the scripts change a
little bit but the story is written way
far in advance like they're pretty much
done writing season 7 they're probably
even working on season 8 now but there's
always a lot of revisions that happen so
like even though they've written this
first script they're probably going to
do a read-through with the cast there'll
be all kinds of changes dialog will
change scenes will get moved around but
what happens is is because they're
gearing up for production like they're
starting to make things those people
need to know which scenes they're going
to be filming so that they can actually
make the props that's why you see early
versions of scripts like this floating
around so if you've ever read like a
script leak sometimes that might be a
really early version of the script not
the actual script that they wind up
shooting with so like if we do see a
very bad girl version of Sansa trying to
act very queenly sitting at the head of
the table at Winterfell
maybe she's wearing a costume that looks
very similar to something that Cersei
would wear you know something very
queenly very powerful looking the
costume department would need to know
about that scene so they could actually
make the dress and that actually reminds
me the costume person the person who
makes a lot of the costumes on Game of
Thrones not this past season but she's
coming on next season was at Comic Con
talking about some ideas that she was
kicking around and she didn't say
exactly who she was developing some
costumes for but she made it sound like
she was going to be making some special
jewelry pieces for Daenerys like
Daenerys Cersei and now Sansa will all
have these very elaborate costumes the
dudes on the other hit like John
just rolls out of bed shakes his hair
and goes to get something to eat like
he's not going to be wearing super
elaborate costumes but there's just a
certain level of pageantry with all the
female characters so just expect that to
get really crazy especially now that
Cersei has crowned herself other really
important story elements so Isaac
Hempstead right was talking about what's
going to be happening next so he's like
the Big Jon Snow Targaryen reveal is
very important to the story going
forward brand this information for a
reason so he imagines that he's going to
be spreading the word far and wide so
that not just Jon Snow but the entire
kingdom knows the truth of the situation
there is a Targaryen heir in the kingdom
so obviously that's going to cause a lot
of chaos he didn't say exactly how he
thinks bran is going to tell that to Jon
Snow but he did say that it's going to
be really funny when he shows up and
tries to tell Jon that he's a tree
wizard in that his father is not his
real father so that was actually one of
my predictions for Season seven is it
like they would explore the idea of Jon Son's
father
whereas season six was the big reveal of
his mother being Lyanna stark in the
other big thing like a little further
south at the Citadel is Samwell so
pretty much everyone believes and they
were implying that what he was doing at
the Citadel would be incredibly
important for the story meaning that
because he has the Valyrian blade he's
probably going to learn how to fight
White Walkers and then he'll communicate
that to Jon so like okay we need
Valyrian blades we need obsidian so
we're going to need to get the dragon
stone and we're going to need to forge more
Valyrian steel but the funny thing that
the actor said is just that you know
like instead of dying in a battle he
would love to be crushed in like a giant
avalanche of books at the Citadel like
it wasn't the battle that got him it was
all the books so you guys can let me
know like what do you think about this
production teaser obviously is going to
be a long time before they start
actually filming scenes so I don't think
that we're going to get like a full trailer
for the season at least until next
spring like I mean it's going to be a long
time and they did confirm that it was
going to be early summer release so it's
going to be like really late-may
early-june before we get episode 1 which
I think we kind of expected and they did
confirm also that it's going to be 7
episodes 7 episodes starting in like
we'll say early June but they didn't
actually say the day like they didn't
give an exact date they just said early
summer so get hype Comic Con continues there is a Walking Dead trailer I'll do
a vid
go for that next but I felt like this
was just there was so much good news
that came out of the game of thrones
panel that I wanted to do a video real
quick and there is a Game of Thrones
giveaway going on right now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I'll do
another follow-up video in a couple days
tomorrow is going to be huge for Marvel
and DC so I'll just I'll post updates
for that whenever I post Marvel DC
videos while you guys wait for that
video to post you can click here for my
Iron Fist trailer video there are two
Game of Thrones actors in that and you
can click here for all my other Game of Thrones Season 7
videos thank you so much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight!